hey comic-con i'm leanna Galera coming
to you live right now with the cast of
Teen Wolf Tyler nice lightsaber Thanks I
brought it yeah you brought it from home
I did yeah it was real careful careful
this is your pack here protect them yeah
we've got to talk about we're going back
to beacon hills July 30th for the final
10 episode of Teen Wolf how surreal is
it to know that this journey is actually
coming to a close easing us yeah yeah
they keep teasing us I think I think now
I fully accepted it like Jeff Jeff
called me on the phone like I feel like
a long time ago before we started
filming last season and was like hey so
I got some news for you
we're not picking it back up the show's
over and it felt right you know it felt
like good timing I knew that we were
going to finish out the hundred episodes
and I felt it felt good to step away you
know I felt okay it was sad because I
didn't want want but but it felt like
good timing and yeah it's it feels if
those weird it's odd it's sad it's it's
a legacy you know team won't became this
huge entity and like with its own life
and personality and no it's no it's no
it's just gonna be like one of those
things that used to be no no it's gonna
live on no no it's gonna live on because
one of the things I love is that Teen
Wolf is already planning its own reboot
we just got the news yesterday that
maybe in a couple years a new class a
new pack could be coming in would any of
you guys be game to at least do a guest
spot and this upcoming reboot down yeah
I want to be a part of I don't know
reading will be your regular ready to
let it go low or you can
can what advice would you guys give to a
new cast coming in to represent employed
family don't complain
don't complain it's a great one no it
was hard we just worked hard and had a
lot of crazy hours and and but the
morale was always awesome on set yeah we
always had a lot of fun I think that's
what made it worth it like we had
16-hour days but with the lack of
complaints and like with everyone just
enjoying what they do it just made life
so much better be Shelley and we also
discovered that when Teen Wolf ends
after these 10 episodes this story will
still live on in podcast form which is
very unique this is all news to us I
know I heard that today what would you
like - yeah please react to that I have
a question there because Jeff recently
he was just like yeah it'll be kind of
like s town I'm like you said a whole
bunch of stuff I was like like well no
that's an odd cast I'm like well how is
Teen Wolf on a podcast gonna be like s
town I mean I got a southern accent
oh I remember I remember I mean you
chunks to this I'm Jim for this
everyone's chunk for this but like they
used to have like radio shows where they
were like radio voices
oh I mean what are we explaining I'm
sorry you know like an on radio years
ago yeah this shows that's kind of what
this was great this is just like we have
the Saints like great Eric - yeah and we
had the faces for radio yeah your TV
we've got to talk about these last ten
episodes I understand we're getting a
little bit of a time jump where we pick
it up with the pack we meet him again
Scott is geriatric we do have a time
jump that jumps ahead in like like two
years so we can't expect a significant
time job we jump to you
all right this is my cast I know you're
weary of spoilers but the trailer did
reveal that we got a trio of familiar
faces coming back into Beacon Hill's we
have Stiles Jackson and Derek walking
the hall
what does it have all three of these
guys back I know this point Charlie no
you're right here you know that I adore
you I know but what was it like first of
all to welcome colton back you guys were
walking down the hall looking oh so
badass together yeah well we're buddies
so we wanted any excuse to get back and
work together so we had a blast we were
laughing the whole time
of course behaving like professionals
exactly but I think everybody's gonna
really love seeing all of these old
Carrie I mean that's what's so special
about ending a show and knowing in
advance that you get to end it is you
know there's enough time to sort of
alert the troops and bring everybody
back to give the fans what they deserve
and for everybody to say goodbye in the
way they should so like that yeah the
troops the one and only Dylan O'Brien
will be making an appearance we don't
know how big his role is gonna be but he
looks like he comes to your aid at some
point what was it like to be able to
have him back in these last 10 episode
oh it was great I mean it's it's one of
the greatest feelings I could have on
set is when he and I are working
together because it reminds me of so
much of when I used to do it with him
and we would just like follow each other
around like puppies my gun set like he
would walk away I would like follow him
and you saw this really funny and silly
dynamic I said it was it was it was nice
to have that again yeah with Teen Wolf
coming to a close what's next for you
guys is there anything that you're
looking forward to doing is there any
makeup you're excited to never have to
put on again I'm gonna miss the blood a
lot miss it sure we'll do it again how
sticky is it depends stains is dangerous
cause made it hard to use the bathroom I
felt it made it more enjoyable to use
the bathroom it's close you would I do
hey yo Tyler we're gonna be seeing you
on Jane the virgin again next year yeah
I was playing jeana's very first love
interest on the show yeah Adam what can
you tease about him uh yeah he's a blast
from the past
he was Gina's character's first love
interest when they were kids
and she had just lost her husband and
has gone through all this turmoil with
her family and I kind of come in and I'm
like this like kind face is just seen in
a while maybe a possible love interest
for her just to kind of get her heart
back in the right place but this is teal
of time babe I know I know but like I
said though yes it was very well said
thank you well we're just trying to
figure out what we're gonna be seeing
you guys next yeah objects that you guys
are excited to talk about today uh I
think there'll be some fun stuff at
comic-con this weekend yeah I've
actually has really classified so it's
just like we think up there
yes yeah yeah yeah exactly tops I should
have sent home now sly come on now
what can you guys tease about these last
ten episodes give us your best one-word
description one word god I mean we'll
take your words if you got em I was
trying to know what is sex and death oh
that's one of those death and also I'm
just like seeing headlines right now and
my team of cops final episode yes what
can we expect from olio though as her
journey comes to an ER oh wow sorry that
was not on purpose she I wasn't prepared
for this uh well I think it's out there
that her and Scott sort of come together
and I like what Jeff was saying about it
it just sort of fit they didn't rush it
and I I do think the fans will be
excited about that
mm-hmm yeah I think they will be I think
that's a final ooh you added an added
element and yeah I'm excited for people
to see the we played around with like
their dynamic and it's not that's
different it's different
he's different from Scott and Malia yes
yes
lastly looking into this camera right
here what is what do you guys want to
say to your team will fans who have been
by your side for the past
almost seven years we're not going
anywhere you all are the best fans in
the world
in all those universes there's a lot of
uteruses and we love you just as much
all the colleges of ecology yeah thank
you guys for sticking with us through
the weird the good the bad sex in the
death the sex that hang out with us to
see what's next we have things that
we're gonna do outside of the Teen Wolf
and hopefully we'll come back to the
wolf one day but I don't know about you
guys but I love these people and I love
you and I really hope that we did a good
job at entertaining showing you that
we're normal real people and we just
like to have fun amazing thank you guys
so much for stopping by I really
appreciate it and thank you all so much
for tuning in ET is gonna be a lot from
Comic Con the entire weekend with all
the cast of your favorite show so stick
with us like subscribe do all that fun
stuff comment and say bye to the cast